but littell good morning thanks for
joining us here on c-span morning to you
pleasure to be here
the book is called the company a novel
of the CIA why did you write it ha
that's a very good question you got me
right on the spot I make my living
writing books this is my 13th published
novel but I wrote this particular one
because of a longstanding fascination
with the subject matter which is the
Cold War and the Cold War from the point
of view of the Central Intelligence
Agency I've been sort of nibbling around
the edges of this book I guess in many
other of my books of my 13 novels about
half of them are espionage novels but
they're all cold war stories and so I
always felt I was nibbling around the
edges of the big book and this is the
big book it meant to detail with
somebody who obviously knows a thing or
two about the inner workings of the CIA
how did you do your research a lot of
people think that I must have been a
member of the CIA or the KGB I was a
member of neither my research actually
took me a full year the first year of
work was nothing but reading reading
reading and making notes and the big
problem that kind of reading is to
organize your material so you can get
the details back when you need them so
the way I did it was I just read and
read and read there's a vast amount of
information out there in book form
article form and I also traveled to the
places I was writing about I went to
Moscow I went to Budapest I went to
Berlin I went to Pakistan in Budapest I
found the gentleman but one of my
sections deals with the Hungarian
Revolution of 1956
I found a gentleman who had participated
in it and he walked me through for two
days all the battle sites and all the
scenes and it was very moving very
interesting to see I mean that's how I
did my research and what did you learn
about Budapest or about the CIA in
general the CIA what I learned about the
CIA was its successes in its failures
this this organization especially in the
early 50s was really on the ramp I think
very courageous people on the ramparts
the Cold War and people forget how
dangerous the Cold War was in the early
50s the book starts out in Berlin when
it was a real killing field when the
Soviets were about a football field away
and we all thought that the Soviet Army
would roll over Berlin to the English
Channel any at any given day the CIA
people used to keep thermite bombs on
their desks and on their safes to
destroy their secrets they figured they
had 10 minutes to get out if the if the
balloon went up is they used to say so I
mean I learned about their successes I
learned about their failures but don't
forget this is fiction and I invented
successes and I invented Phillies try to
incorporate this into at least one of
the headlines from this morning's New
York Times which takes a look at
government agencies overall and how they
have reacted since September 11th to
terrorism and specifically Phillip
Shannon writes about the the way these
agencies are collaborating or sharing
information or not doing so the CIA is
mentioned in all of this when you look
at a government bureaucracy like this
how does it all work how does it all
come together I think you put it you
think I didn't read the story but I saw
the headline you're putting your finger
on one of the great problems that led to
11 September which was the lack of
coordination between the various
intelligence agencies and establishments
in Washington in America curiously the
director of Central Intelligence is
supposed to direct all the American
intelligence operations but in practice
he'd ever really did and we're now
learning about for example about that
FBI memo that was that came out of
Phoenix in which an FBI agent drew
attention to the large number of Arab
men who were taking flight training that
memo never made it to another person who
might have had another detail I mean
it's all a puzzle and to put the pieces
of the puzzle together and coordination
between the different agencies is a huge
problem Homeland Security Director Tom
Ridge is expected on July 1st to unveil
to the president his recommendations for
changes when it comes to homeland
security do you have an opinion on what
you think he should include in that
memorandum I think
I think the first thing that has to be
done there's no question that 11
September must be seen as one of the
great intelligence failures of American
history it's right up there with pearl
hobbits right up there with the Bay of
Pigs and the interesting thing about
those two events was they were both
followed they were both followed by
Commission's independent and very high
powered commissions which examined where
America went wrong there was no CIA at
the time of Pearl Harbor but these
Commission's examine the problem and the
the idea being that we should make sure
America doesn't go wrong in the same way
again now what I've noticed is that
since 11 September nobody nobody has
been studying the CIA presumably the CIA
is studying itself but can the CIA
examine itself I doubt it very much I
doubt whether any organization can
investigate itself Congress is just
beginning to scratch the surface and we
learned last week when they let go their
chief investigator that he was former
CIA yeah you know we have to start now
with a with a high-powered independent
investigative body that can look at the
American intelligence establishment and
see where it went wrong I mean in 1991
when the Soviet Union disintegrated when
the Berlin Wall came down America and
the in general and the intelligence
organizations in particular they lost
their enemy it seems to me that the
adrenaline stopped flowing that they
stopped they got out of the business of
taking risks they got out of the
business of telling people in Washington
things they didn't want to hear shops
were closed down by shops I mean
stations all over the world CIA
operatives were retired out in droves to
the point where we can read now with to
the point where there were no linguists
capable of debriefing Taliban defectors
or even more ironic when the CIA had
Taliban intercepts from these cell phone
as they use there was nobody in the CIA
who could translate them and they
shopped him out to the Pakistani secret
service
is ironic because the Pakistani Secret
Service created the Taliban and they
were the stepchild of the Pakistani
secret service which of course for its
own strategic reasons wanted to ring
India with Islamic states so I mean we
need to now step back and take a look at
the mindset of the CIA and the other
intelligence establishment and where
they were wrong and then set it right
our conversation is with Robert littell
he has written more than a dozen novels
including one of his most recent ones
the company a look at the CIA our phone
lines are open
we'll get your calls in just a moment or
you can email us at journal at c-span
org we spent about three hours with Tom
Clancy a couple months ago and he said
as a fiction writer in his wildest
imagination he never could have
envisioned the events of September 11 is
that one of the reasons why we didn't
anticipate it you said earlier it was a
communications breakdown I you know
America America's security was so lacks
airport security and now we read about
reservoir security and we're worried now
about trucks coming into the cities
nobody's got a handle on this yet I
thought that in with hindsight that what
the CIA should have done before 11
September was gathered together Clancy
and some of the other more imaginative
writers around a table like this and say
how would you attack America if you if
you were Islamic fundamentalist and you
wanted to do wanted to hurt America that
might have come up with a with an answer
Madison Wisconsin good morning our first
call for mr. littell good morning
gentlemen I served on the border there
in the Fulda gap and I was there on the
border I will try to fix the audio if we
could go ahead caller
we don't really know I was just saying
that I was a soldier on the Fulda gap of
when the wall fell there and I was very
fascinated with the whole aspect of the
Cold War and a lot of the lore and
legend that soldiers heard about when we
were there and I was just wondering of
mr. little good
sure a couple of those stories with us
this morning about the wool coming down
uh about things of operations that the
CIA had like we heard about caches a
weapon so sure I've had Jordan sure
there was some great there was some
great classical and legendary CIA
operations in the early days of the Cold
War
you probably remember some of them you
remember when they dug a tunnel under
Berlin from the American sector to the
Soviet sector and for 18 months they
were tapping into the Soviet phone lines
and getting tons of information from
that the u2 was another enormous success
remember the u2 operation and that was a
CIA operation because they gave the ball
to the CIA because the Air Force would
have taken eight years to get the plane
off the ground think the CIA did it in
18 months something like that and they
were getting enormous amount of
information on Soviet capabilities and
Soviet distribution of forces and that
kind of thing the stories of spying
across the Berlin Wall uh my fiction I
invent stories like that about defectors
and that you know the story of Volkov
the famous Soviet defective Volkov who
turned up in Istanbul in the early days
of the Cold War he was a diplomat but he
was KGB and he he got in touch with a
with a British diplomat and said I
wanted the fact with my family I have a
lot of information including information
that can lead you to identify a Soviet a
Soviet mole inside mi6 which was a
British secret service this information
he said don't radio it back because
we're monitoring your radio send it back
by pouch this information was sent back
to London by pouch and wound up on the
desk of Kim Philby who was the man in
charge of anti Soviet operations the man
in charge with anti Soviet operations
for mi6 was a soviet mole Philby went to
his boss and said this is so important
that I should go out there myself and
get the defective
myself he took three days to get there
and of course by the time he got there
for mr. Volkoff and his family no longer
were around they had been carried off
back to Russia and disappeared
spies doors they go on and on and
they're great the company a novel of the
CIA by overlook pres Robert littell is
the author
this is his 13th book our next call is
London England go ahead please
good afternoon I've traveled around
Eastern Europe Afghanistan placed like
that and in the 70s I noticed the CIA
all over Afghanistan I think Europeans
see a totally different way we never saw
Russia as a threat
when the Americans and the Russians
joined up in space the Russian satellite
had to fly as highest and the American
is lowest because they were so backward
we always knew they were backward we
wouldn't win a cell friend we felt more
threatened by America's invasions of
Russian territory we thought that would
lead to war I mean like I said in
Afghanistan all over Europe Turkey Iran
you saw these white Americans who said
they were working for the Peace Corps
but I were a bit too volt and the CIA
they've got everything from her three
years and I think they've invaded
virtually every country and America the
reason why a lot of people don't like
America is I don't think you can name a
single country that America hasn't been
to war with it went to Libya 200 years
ago it was a war with Libya we invaded
every country in Europe including
Britain France Germany Italy Spain you
name it just goes amnon and the CIA
seems to be the most incompetent I don't
know where they get their recruits from
well if you think America is the enemy I
think you got it completely backward
you're forgetting you're forgetting the
Cold War and you're forgetting the
threat from from the Soviet Union and
you're forgetting even in Berlin in the
1950s the Soviet troops and the Soviet
armaments outnumbered the three allies
combined
and there were there were many people
and many many military thinkers who
thought that the Soviet Union could
wanted to go across Europe up to the
English Channel and that if they if they
wanted to that Stalin don't forget until
1953 they couldn't do it in six weeks
you know if you're looking at the CIA
and America is their enemy you have it
really backwards let's not forget who
liberated Europe in World War two let's
not forget the Marshall Plan let's not
forget the American aid all over the
world that's not to say that the CIA
didn't didn't have big boondoggles
ethical when you make a mistake in him
in English I think boondoggle is a good
word over the years
I mean I'm prepared to go along with you
in terms of a Budapest for example I'll
give you two examples the guy who was
the man who was the deputy director of
plans at the time his name was Weisner
wasn't satisfied with the idea of being
a rampart against the Soviet Union he
wanted a roll back communism and America
was doing under under this deputy
director plans of the CIA was doing what
it could to roll back communism and to
liberate the slave states don't forget
they were slave states I've been to
Bulgaria many times
curiously over the years and all the
other East European countries I visited
them all and I visited the Soviet Union
many times and they were under a
dominated by a terrible system so
Weisner decided to roll about communism
I would go back to Budapest when finally
after being invited to rise up one
people did which was the the freedom
fighters in Hungary America just left
them out on the line to dry President
Eisenhower and and his Secretary of
State Dulles decided that the United
States wasn't going to risk World War
three for for some rebels fighting for
their own liberation in Budapest and in
Hungary so that was one great error and
the second that comes to mind
immediately I do a whole section on
Budapest and then I do another whole
on the Bay of Pigs the Bay of Pigs is
unbelievable to read into it now 40
years later you you are hard put to
understand how it was so dumb how they
could launch an operation that was so
that had such small chance of success
let's not forget they were landing 1600
Cuban Patriots on a remote beach
surrounded by a swamp and these people
were supposed to defeat Castro's army of
200,000 men I think the big mystery
which I address in my fictional way is
why Kennedy who was supposed to be a
smart cookie and why the people around
Kennedy who were supposed to be smart
signed off on this and that had to do
with his relationship with Judith Exner
who wrote a book about this by the way
before she died about the fact that she
was sharing a bed with the president the
United States and also with Giancana who
was the mafia chief of Chicago but this
is all but you think that lists the Bay
of Pigs I think that's why Kennedy
signed off on the Bay of Pigs I think
that's why he gave them the go-ahead to
try to do what they were doing because I
think he was convinced that that the CIA
was trying to assassinate Castro through
the Mafia and I think he had inside
information that they were going to do
it and it didn't do it
Chicago Democrats lying good morning
good morning I have a couple of things
um I was watching um Fox News Fox Cable
News and they said that the reason that
the United States was looking for Osama
bin Laden is because that they got a
report from Yemen that Osama bin Laden
and other had met in Yemen and that was
the reason that they thought Osama bin
Laden had something to do with the world
tracing bombers then Yemen said that
they never said that and they were
supposed to retract the statement and
then they said Osama bin Laden had
nothing to do with the World Trade
Centers so I'm wondering why they are
still Obama desk and Afghanistan and
still killing the people over there and
then second thing
I heard like when they're going to a
suit Sudan and Afghanistan can fight
that the majority of these soldiers are
that they're fighting our children
between the age of 8 and 12 can you give
me some insight on that well I think the
first thing I care to say is that today
it's an open and closed case about Osama
bin bin Laden's responsibilities in the
World Trade Center attack simply there's
a smoking gun look at the tapes the
clips in which he talks about it and
admits it so if you think that he's not
responsible you have to go back and take
a look at these news clips that
everybody's seen and there's no doubt
about that
the interesting thing about bin Laden is
he's been around a long time I handed
this book in to my publisher who is
Peter mayor of overlook press one year
in one week before 11 September and I
have Osama bin Laden as a character in
the book in the section on Afghanistan
and I have so I mean I was already
interested in the problem and the
problem was that America America seemed
to be creating its own enemy by arming
and encouraging the Mujahideen the way
we did without reservations we were we
were preparing and arming the people who
would attack us next they made no bones
about the fact I'm talking about the
fundamentalist that when they got rid of
the Soviet Union from Afghanistan we
were the next on their list we were the
next target and America has this short
side forever has this short sighted
during the Cold War it's short-sighted
anti-communism which was anything that
was anti Soviet we were four and
Afghanistan in those days I'm talking
about the the war this is before the
Taliban the war against the Russian
forces when they occupied Afghanistan
that was I think a President Reagan and
Casey who was the head of the the
director of the CIA saw this as payback
time
for Vietnam Vietnam the Russians
supported the people we were fighting in
in Vietnam
55,000 or more American soldiers were
killed 900 and more than 900 planes were
shot down by Russian missiles and I
think they saw the Russians in a
quagmire and it was payback time and
they didn't look past that which was
often the problem during the Cold War
about American foreign policy
it just went this far and didn't go far
enough this novel spans about 40 years
45 what was your approach in that uh
I'll tell you how it began I was at I
had published another novel with
overlooked pres and Peter Mayer who's
the publisher we were at lunch in New
York one day and he threw out an idea he
suggested that I should I might want to
think about doing a multi-generational
saga of the Cold War and the CIA and the
successes and failures over over a
period from the early days CIA was
created in 1948 by Harry Truman Till and
let's say the 90s and the idea
immediately attracted me the the
possibilities of humanizing the CIA of
putting a human face on the CIA I think
it's something that the fiction writer
can get at perhaps more than a
nonfiction writer to create characters
my characters come out of Yale which was
in the early 50s practically a farm team
for the CIA the famous and James Jesus
Angleton was Yale the Yale rowing coach
was a talent scout for the CIA and so my
characters there in the early part of
the book come out of Yale into the CIA
and I wanted to carry them through the
Cold War through the great episodes of
the Cold War
and at the same time try to humanize the
CIA and show the the in-house fighting
the the gallantry the courage and the
and the dumbness in certain areas next
call San Diego on the Republican line
for Robert littell good morning a
question I have for you is the why is it
that the United States and not just the
CIA but the FBI do you think based on
your research it have trouble adapting
to the changing environments in the
world I know the FBI once the Cold War
ended focused on street gangs and prison
gangs and was going to try them under
Rico statutes federal RICO statutes that
was one way that they were trying to
adapt to the end of the Cold War but but
I've noticed that the Congress has
trouble with it and most the federal
government has trouble adapting to the
changing environment in the world I'm
more prepared to talk about the CIA than
the FBI but what I will say is that I
think it has a lot to do with mindset
the CIA when it lost its enemy and which
is to say when the Soviet Union
disintegrated and we have to add a
parenthetical idea here that the CIA
didn't predict the disintegration of the
Soviet Union with the collapse of the
Soviet empire but when it when they lost
their enemy the CIA changed it seems to
me it got much more timid as an
organization and its mindset toward
terrorism in the 90s was more or less
this is something to be controlled but
not conquered this wasn't the way the
CIA attacked the KGB during the Cold War
this were the KGB was an enemy that
would be converted and conquered and
beaten terrorism seemed to be something
you just controlled so I think the main
problem in the 90s with the CIA had to
do with mindset the company is the
latest in a series of books by Arthur
including the October circle Mother
Russia the amateur the once and future
spy an agent in place to name a few our
next call is West Midland inland good
morning good morning do me a favor turn
the volume down I haven't got any follow
your mother go ahead Sam the CIA and
hasn't it been for years as we've known
in the West that that the CIA have been
secretly am training mercenaries for
terrorism to go out through all the
countries in the world that they didn't
the the her government said that he
didn't like about now I see on the CNN
that they've suddenly opened up and and
and you're not secretive anymore in that
anyway can you tell me why you go into
other countries where the human rights
are are chronic and you don't do it
through human rights your self and that
you're going against it or it it's not
really like the rest of the world wants
it but you decide to stand on your own
well you've always liked to but this is
a new living now it's a new century and
you've got to come up into this world
now it's very interesting to see what a
bad reputation the CIA has in the world
today I don't share your feeling about
what it was doing the CIA there you know
it made its mistakes but basically the
people inside it are not murderers and
not killers and they're not trying to
bring down every government in the world
that they don't they don't agree with do
you know that there was a there's a
United States law that prohibits the CIA
from assassinating foreign leaders and
as far as I know with the exception of
their their efforts against Castro and
there was one in Africa too they pretty
much stuck to that over the years the
CIA
isn't as bad as you think it is they're
not everywhere bringing down every
government that crosses the United
States it just doesn't work that way
they really from the nineties on became
an intelligence collection agency more
than an Operations agency because they
closed down all those shops all those
stations all over the world and they
were basically listening in on
communication and eavesdropping
collecting information and trying to
analyze the information to see who the
potential enemies were of course they
didn't do the job well enough to prevent
11 September go back to the headlines
from over the weekend this is
yesterday's Washington Post on Friday
Robert Hansen 58 years old an FBI agent
for 25 years and spent about 20 years
selling secrets to the Russian
government telling a judge I am shamed
he'll spend the rest of his life in
prison what do we learn from a case like
this I think the first thing we learn
from the sentence why he was sent to
prison for life as opposed to being
subjected to execution was that he's
going to be debriefed for the rest of
his life they are going to stay on this
guy once a week once a month all the
time they want him available for years
and years they want him available so
they can find out what he gave away and
as they put pieces of this puzzle
together they're going to go back to him
I think he's going to be bored to death
in his jail sentence but just by the
debriefings could there be other Robert
Hansen's now in the FBI
if history tells us anything now I
wouldn't speak about the FBI but if
history tells us anything Aldrich turned
up in the CIA Hansen turned up in the
FBI we'd be we'd be naive to think that
there aren't others around the place the
the motivation for betraying your
country has to do with them there's
there are several we know in Hansen's
case that it was money but I also feel
that had to do with the fact that he was
running the FBI's he was not he was very
much involved in the FBI's anti-soviet
operations and I think the adrenaline
must have been flowing I think he got a
he may have started out for the money
but he must have gotten a big charge
out of being the man who was supposed to
be catching the guy he was you see what
I mean
and the these drops under bridges and
getting leaving them stuff for the
Russians in garbage sacks and getting
money back and all that it's this added
a thrill to a life that looked to be
very humdrum mundane I think this part
of it the psychological explanation that
sure there will be others yeah sorry
that's okay Charlotte North Carolina
independent line for Robert littell good
morning well I'm trying to be ready with
a good question lost to be ready with an
answer I get lost and I get found then I
get lost and why why are you lost
why am I lost well I just you know I'm
one of these people that communicates
very directly to directly for my own
good that guy called the CIA to offer to
help and that was a big mistake but
anyway I wanted to ask mister littell is
that correct that's right
okay have you read this it's an old book
it was my father's and I found it in
some a box of my mother had of his and
it it's called the invisible government
no are you familiar with that well it's
it's really old it's from I think it was
published in the early 60s but it's
written by David Weiss and Thomas Ross
and it's about the CIA why did I stand
out beside the fact that your dad had it
oh because he's talking about the CIA
there today nobody in your own line why
do you remember the book I especially
remember the Bay of Pigs incident and
the pilots that flew the mission being
from Birmingham Alabama that's right
which is where we grew up that's right
that was where I lived and my father was
in the Air Force at the time and my dad
had already passed away but I wondered
if he might have known those men I
believe that he did no I don't know
those people personally but I know the
story you're absolutely right this
CIA took pilots from the Air Force they
the expression I used was sheep dip they
cheap dip them I don't know where that
expression even comes from and these
were the pilots who went down and
trained the Cuban pilots so that they
could fly the missions against Castro's
Air Force and eventually try to protect
the the 1600's will put ashore on the
beaches there was a moment during the
Bay of Pigs when things were going very
bad and Kennedy refused to let he always
said that he would never commit overtly
commit American forces no matter how bad
things got one of the problems in the
Bay of Pigs I and I covered this in my
fictional way was that the people - CIA
the man the architect in the CIA was a
gentleman named Bissell and he and
others around him were absolutely
absolutely convinced that if things got
bad enough that Kennedy would relent and
would send in the American planes off
the aircraft carriers which were right
there right off Cuba Kennedy meant what
he said he never did it because he was
thinking of he had a larger horizons he
was thinking of Berlin and what could
happen in Berlin dies in retaliation but
to go back to your pilots things got so
bad on the beach that these pilots from
Birmingham who were training the Cubans
in in Latin America at one point they
got in two airplanes and they flew a
mission themselves and when when the
Kennedys learned about this one of the
planes was shot down and the men were
killed Americans were killed and the
Kennedys when they learned about this
they were furious that they had done
this but it shows the deep commitment
that these pilots from Birmingham had to
the Cuban Patriots who were trying to
overthrow Castro Robert littell is a
graduate of Alfred University previously
worked for Newsweek magazine and as we
said earlier has written more than a
dozen novels what's more difficult
writing news accounts for a publication
like Newsweek or writing novels novels
novels are very difficult when you start
out when I when my publisher sent me the
first copy of this book and I opened it
up to the first line
it was an amazing thing for me to reread
the first line and to remember the day I
sat down at my desk because I couldn't
see the end of the tunnel
the end of the tunnel in the printed
version is 900 pages away when I handed
it in I'm an old-fashioned writer I
don't send in diskettes or email books
in I delivered a manuscript in a box and
it weighed three kilograms and my French
friends I live in France you know and my
French friends said that littell writes
a kilo a year next call comes to us from
Myrtle Beach South Carolina Democrats
lying good morning you're on c-span oh
yes good morning um I had a question to
ask mr. littell um I believe it was in
1979 that an author named John Marx did
a book called the search Manchurian
Candidate the CIA and mine Control
Center this book was a history of how
the CIA had gotten quite deeply involved
with experimentation with LSD starting
with its discovery from Albert Hofmann
in Switzerland and they essentially
experimented with LSD for years
throughout the 1950s probably well into
the nineteen sixties there was a
congressional hearing I believe was in
77
according to mr. Marx and essentially
the hearing didn't go anywhere and since
then there really hasn't been any
information on this topic and I was
wondering if mr. littell knows anything
about this and what he can say about
this I probably know what you know which
is I remember reading about the the CIA
did get interested in the early days and
did experiments with LSD to see what
effect it would have on Picon on people
they did controlled experiments and I
even believe that they subjected people
to these experiments without their
permission I think there was a bit of a
scandal about that a few years ago but I
don't think this ever went anywhere in a
serious way email from a viewer
by the way our email addresses journal
at c-span dot or don't forget the hyphen
between the C and the S in your novel do
you reach any conclusions as the role of
the CIA in the modern world
I I think I do I think my own view is
that America certainly needs an
intelligence establishment and
especially today the the world is a very
dangerous place there are a lot of
people out there who want to harm us and
we need an intelligence establishment
that can do today what the CIA did for
us in the early 50s which is to form a
barrier between us in them to to discern
who our enemies are what their
capabilities are and just because there
were bad moments in CIA history the Bay
of Pigs is the one we keep talking about
but there were others
I don't think senator Moynihan before he
retired from the Senate suggested that
we disband the CIA and start from
scratch I'm not sure that's what's
needed but I to go back to what I said
to you before I think the first thing
one does after an intelligence failure
of this magnitude I'm talking about 11
September is we have to get outside
people to sit down and take a good long
hard look at the organization to see
where it went wrong and I also come from
a culture a Navy culture in the sense
that I spent four years in the United
States Navy and my Navy culture taught
me that the captain is responsible for
ship there was the United States
destroyer once named the Hobson and the
the captain was asleep in his sea cabin
and a young lieutenant junior grade or
ensign was on the bridge maneuvering
with an aircraft carrier and by mistake
he turned right instead of left and the
Hobson was cut in half I wonder how many
people today remember that I think 50 or
more sailors were killed the captain was
responsible for this failure the
submarine that came up what about a year
ago underneath the Japanese ship as soon
as the submarine got back to port the
captain was relieved of his command now
I'm not suggesting that the director the
CIA should have been relieved the day
after or the week after or the month
after but I think the director of the
CIA who was there at 9:00
Timber who's still there the director of
operations who was there at 9 September
and who's still there I think eventually
these people should be treated as the
captain of a ship is treated I think
they should take responsibility for the
this incredible intelligence failure why
do you live in France because I'm
married to a French woman that's a good
reason isn't it and this photograph and
the jacket of the book where was it
taken that was taken by my son
it was taken on a bridge in Budapest and
my that was so interesting the idea of
retracing the steps of the Hungarian
Revolution I told you about the
gentleman who showed me around for two
days my son is a painter and he lives in
Prague and I invited him to come down to
share the experience by way of educating
both of us and he was he didn't regret
it at all so he took the picture my son
took the picture on a bridge in Budapest
next call for Robert Latino author of
the company
Bernie Texas Republican line good
morning hey c-span good to hear y'all
everyday I've been watching you for ten
years just luttrell
I'm a former Submariner myself Atlantic
Fleet Information sheepdip it's what
ranchers do with their cattle especially
sheep they run them through a
combination of water and some agents
that will kill off any ticks and
parasites that might be living on the
sheep's skin in order to keep them
healthy and also in addition to our lady
right and honorable lady and gentlemen
of the liberal or labor persuasion who
had called in early from Britain I think
it should be pointed out that naval
proceedings I think of as back around 94
after the fall of the wall it came in to
West German government hands
considerable amount of paperwork from
the Stasi the intelligence arm of the
East German government and included the
war plans and the political arrangements
that had already been made between both
East German and Russian in the event of
the ball going
over on the on the border
I'll stop be there we'll get a response
if you want to comment no first I'm a
very appreciative for someone to explain
to me the expression sheepdip now i
you've added to my knowledge and I agree
with what you was suggesting which is to
contradict the the woman who called in
before we know who the enemy was they
were they were a serious enemy out there
and you're right about the Stasi papers
and the Stasi plans and it was it was a
killing field it was a tough period of
time there Washington DC independent
line good morning good morning mr.
Liddell uh I haven't read your book yet
I will definitely a couple questions
first what is your perspective on the
process of spirits work in Russia and
the role of KGB within that process and
second if you'd be kind to give any
contact information that I will drop you
a mine and we have an email address so
public you could use the email address
for this for this program if you'd like
and it would get to me about you're
asking about 15
he's ex-kgb of course he made his whole
career in the KGB he came up through the
KGB and I think his mentality is a KGB
mentality the KGB has been disbanded not
backed up and disbanded it's been given
a facelift so they no longer call it the
KGB but there are Soviet and they're not
Soviet Russian security agencies today
and I don't doubt for a moment that the
Soviet president being from that culture
would not hesitate to use those now give
you one example right away is that he
went into Chechnya if you remember in
the wake of the three explosions that
blew up three apartment houses in Moscow
I don't think there's anybody I know in
Moscow who thinks the Chechens did that
most people great many people think that
it was a put-up job in order to give him
an excuse to go into Chechnya and
crackdown which he subsequently did and
he's still there I can add to that that
one of the problems for me in any case
about the President Bush's widespread
all-inclusive war on terrorism is it
seems to be giving cover to anybody in
the world who wants to crack down on
legitimate independence movements
poutine is cracking down on Chechens who
want independence they're not terrorists
the Chinese are cracking down on the we
gore's who are an Islamic people who
have an independence movement that's
just a footnote to to my poutine comment
in your first note in the book writes
about the creation of the KGB it wasn't
known as that he went through II went
through a series of names from the Cheka
at the time of the Revolution on up
through the KGB and what is the deputy
director for operations that's the the
head of the clan the clandestine service
of the CIA in the old days it was called
a deputy director for plans or the ND
and the city and the service was called
the director of plans and at some point
they changed it to operations they just
changed the words next call Fort
Lauderdale Florida
good morning on the Democrats line by
morning I have one question and this
lead back to what the earlier question
were like ah the question was uh I think
should history be emphasized more in the
public school earlier you said that I'm
your guest they said that the
administration of John Kennedy started
they'd be a big incident I can tell you
that history of red said that the under
the dollars on the administration on the
Dwight Eisenhower's party the DfE
incident III how can you say that right
now you're distorting history well I'm
not sure what the question is but
history certainly should be taught and
a real history should be taught of yes
the old story that those who don't know
history are condemned to repeat it
and there's another quotation which at
each time you repeat it it gets more
expensive so I the teaching of history
from my point of view is one of the
principal things that should go into
anybody's education I remember when I
was at university I went to a very
wonderful school called Alfred
University upstate New York and my
history and political science courses
are still with me
and perhaps influenced me a great deal
in my Durer in the direction I went
toward journalism and eventually toward
writing Republican line Eureka South
Dakota good morning good morning um I
happen to know of men but the name of
Major Pedro de vlaamse he was the first
man who be in charge of the air force
for Castro and he was a cancerous
personal pilot and fought with Castro
all through this year me asked me extra
regime and he told me that he used to
fly to the United States Indies with his
plane and the CIA was loaded up his
plane with arms and ammunition and he
told how the CIA helped Castro overthrow
the Batista regime in Cuban it seems to
be the same scenario we see the
countries that are friendly to us from
the Shah of Iran - to the Niger Diaz
Nicaragua we see what's the Somoza down
there and you see the CIA was involved
in the overthrow of virtually
governments that are friendly to the
United States and not enemies of the
United States and it seems to be their
regular uh operation as the CIA has
never really been friendly to this
country it seems their enemies is the
ones they're helping all the time and if
you take a look at bin Laden sir CIA
created this man out so we financed him
and I don't know it's very suspicious
things is that that I see for instance I
see one of the CIA directors met with
him two months before this happened he
was in the hospital in Saudi Arabia and
he was in the hospital
purring with bin Laden I'm not sure that
particular story has ever been confirmed
I remember seeing that story but I'm not
sure it's been confirmed but let me talk
about Castro and use that as an example
to answer I answer your larger question
you mustn't forget that when Castro came
out of the Sierra masters and and took
over Cuba he came out as a liberator
from a very autocratic regime the
Batista regime and he was viewed by the
Cubans as a liberator and he was viewed
by the United States as a potential
Democrat who could bring reforms to the
island it was only later perhaps when he
was what we don't know what was in
Castro's mind from the very beginning
but perhaps because of Che Guevara and
others around him that he began to began
to sound first like a socialist and then
he began to sound like a communist and
then he began to sound like a client of
the Soviet Union so I don't think you
can fault - CIA for the evolution of
Castro who at the very beginning was
simply seen as a hero and a liberator
former President Carter meeting with
Castro tonight it is on Wednesday yes is
Fidel Castro in power until his death oh
I should think so yes and when he does
pass away who takes over yes I certainly
don't know as I I don't know next call
is from Charleston South Carolina good
morning you're on c-span our independent
line good morning I look at your program
a lot and I enjoy are you familiar with
a book called decent interval the author
by Frank snapped I believe came out in
the late 70s well I understand it was
banned in the United States especially
when it came out to print and may be
incorrect but I encountered the book in
South America
I'm retired green beret it was on the
operation security detail that went into
Jonestown and trying counter to look at
and I just wanted your opinion on the
book I remember the book absolutely I
think it's probably incorrect not
probably I think it's incorrect to
suggest that any book has been banned in
America this is a free country
publishers are free to publish what they
want and people are free to buy what
they want I that book was never banned
in America the the subject matter of the
book of course being an ex-green beret
you will feel the irony of it that
America at a certain point in his
Vietnam policy was only buying time it
wanted from the title of the book a
decent interval to pass between the time
that so they could get out of Vietnam
and say and back out of it's more or
less gracefully a lot of people on both
sides were killed during what we call
the decent interval so it's a moment of
irony let me go back there's a story in
this week's edition of US News and World
Report out on newsstands tomorrow by
Chitra Raghavan who writes that among
the other things that are being proposed
over the FBI is a major shift for Robert
Muller this is a quote he wants to
consolidate all terrorism investigations
at the bureau's Washington DC
headquarters rather than allow field
offices to take the lead he will also
more than double the resources for this
new division adding 100 new intelligence
analysts to shore up the FBI's chronic
weaknesses with strategy and Muller also
says that he plans to recruit more
Arabic speakers and short supply right
now the FBI about time but but the main
problem is not going to be I'm
absolutely sure that everybody's beefing
up their anti-terrorism organizations
CIA and the FBI and the others too the
main problem is going to be sharing
information to be organizing things so
that the different organizations can put
on the table what they know I mean
solving intelligence problems is like
solving a jigsaw puzzle you get little
pieces of information and you put it
together on a table and you need to have
access to all the information I'll give
you one detail which you probably are
familiar with out of
we know now that the CIA was told was
informed by three foreign intelligence
organizations that bin Laden had
summoned home one of his four wives from
Syria back to Afghanistan I think two or
three weeks before 11 September if this
isn't a piece of a jigsaw puzzle what is
but where were the people who were
putting all this on one table and
looking at all the other pieces of
information I think over the years now
as time goes on we're going to see more
and more details what I call pieces of
the jigsaw puzzle coming out and I mean
my whole approach to my book was to look
at the intelligence operations as a big
jigsaw puzzle and that's what's on the
cover of the book if you remember by the
way a previous caller had asked how they
can get a hold of mr. littell if you do
want to email us at journal at c-span
org and we'll put it on the screen you
can do so when we will make sure that he
gets your emails questions or comments
our next call is winston-salem North
Carolina good morning to you on the
Republican line a good mo a good morning
this is my first call I do was your
program and I enjoy it and I just
haven't turned on this morning and mr.
lapel sparked a memory with me the men
that that went into Cuba the 1600 they
were released if I'm not mistaken eaten
late 1963 or early 1964 is that correct
it is they eventually the Kennedy
administration I believe traded tractors
and another things to get these men out
so they were eventually bought bought
out they were brought into Fort Jackson
South Carolina and I was training in
basic training the second company from
top of thought what they call tank Hill
and they brought the Cubans into some
barracks across the street or road from
us and half the training company I was
in was Puerto Rican our Puerto Rican
National Guard and these folks did not
get along at all between the these of
free Cubans and the Puerto Ricans I just
don't I hadn't thought about that
years and just listing you that came
back what happened to the men after they
left Fort Jackson on how long did they
stay there because course I left when my
train was oh I I really don't know in
detail I think some of them were
employed by the CIA eventually but the
great mass just went back to civilian
life and went back to their lives
and many of them came out of Miami they
had lived in Miami they were recruited
in Miami and I suppose they went back to
their their families in their lives on
the Republican line Detroit good morning
yeah I was wondering what connection
that Harbor north had with the CIA in
the case of drug coming into the country
we liked that we had a play here in
Detroit that landed and rosy land naval
base south of Detroit it had drugs and
nothing was ever said about did you just
find you research find out anything
about that no I don't I don't that
doesn't ring any bells with me I know
that you're talking about Casey and
Oliver North and the iran-contra thing
we know that they were selling weapons
through they were they were getting
weapons from Israel to Iran they were
taking the money and then using that
money in an unaccountable way in other
words they didn't have to go to Congress
to get money so they had funds that this
was Casey's surely Casey's invention and
Oliver North was a trooper in in this
case the operation but about the drugs
I'm not familiar with that at all
Chicago our independent line good
morning good morning mr. littell I'm a
big fan of yours and congratulations in
your book I have a question what ever
happened to a man named Jimmy Fox he
died suddenly after I guess at the World
Trade Center and the Russian mafia Expo
they exposed the Russian mafia in
Brighton Beach in the area of New York
suddenly mr. Fox died from I believe
food poisoning do you know anything
about that no but you want to write a
novel about it it sounds very intriguing
I don't know anything about it now
Kenneth Harbor Maine good morning
Robert littell yes the lady a while back
mentioned reading a book called the
invisible government do you remember
that I remember the question yeah
yes well I'm my ears perked right up
because I'm reading a book called the
invisible government but it's by a
different author than when she mentioned
the one I'm reading is by dan smoot just
an ex-fbi men and it's all about the the
Council on Foreign Relations and the
trilateral and all of that stuff and the
book is loaded with them kind of people
and so is our government and the news
people like dan Rather and Tom Brokaw
Barbara Walters Marvin and Bernard calve
John Chancellor Walter Cronkite they're
all CFR members and things like and I
don't understand why the people who
don't start finding out about things
like this all they have to do is go to
that library I'll call the John Birch
Society they've got all kind of
information on these kind of people yeah
is he suggesting that all these people
are CIA members well he's still on the
line ID are you see up I see you High
Council on Foreign Relations okay I
heard CIA uh I can't say anything about
that except that if you think there's a
great conspiracy going on I couldn't
agree with you less you're talking about
very distinguished American news people
and I don't see a great conspiracy going
on except to bring the news to the
American people what's the message from
the company I don't think it's a book
with a message I think it's a book it's
a historical novel and it's a book about
the Cold War and history and I don't
think it has any message it's supposed
to bid pretends to be you know graham
greene's famous expression that he wrote
entertainments the first thing a
novelist does is he wants to tell the
story and entertain his readers after
that if there's a layers bedrock of real
history and real events and real
characters because I interlace my
fictional characters with many of the
legendary CIA people and that's a bonus
from the book robert littell thank you
for being with us thank you it was a
great pleasure